cultive au plan international elle est
très évolutive et donc nous mêmes en
martinique nous adaptons de dispositifs
de réponse à l'évolution
ce n'est pas une réunion de
communication pour rassurer la
population mais pour informer c'est par
ces mots que le préfet a qualifié sa
rencontre avec les parlementaires
concernant le coronavirus une réunion de
travail basée sur la prévention sommes
quand même territoire où on n'a pas
encore dénombré on n'a pas encore eu de
cas mais de toute façon ça peut arriver
à n'importe quel moment on n'est jamais
prêt à affronter ce genre de choses donc
justement ce que nous voulions c'est que
monsieur le préfet et électeurs puissent
être en mesure de porter une
communication juste envers la population
pour catherine conconne l'inquiétude des
martiniquais concernant le virus est
légitime mais selon la sénatrice la
sérénité est primordial afin de ne pas
se laisser emporter par l'affolement
la martinique n'est pas à l'abri ce que
nous vivons dans le monde nous recevons
des passagers tous les jours elias
plusieurs transatlantiques qui déversent
des passages dans ce moment nous sommes
en pic de saison touristique
donc il faut pouvoir envisager cette
situation en sérénité en toute lucidité
et puis quels sont les moyens qui sont
mis à disposition de la lutte contre
cette pandémie
face au co vite 10,9 des mesures ont été
annoncées concernant les ports les
marinas et l'aéroport pour l'aéroport
une présence contrôles sanitaires aux
frontières de l' agence régionale de
santé avec une distribution pour ceux
qui le souhaitent d'informations
complémentaires sur la conduite à tenir
lors de cette rencontre le préfet est
revenu sur la sphère de l'avion en
provenance d'italie qui a mobilisé les
associations l'avion qui est prévue
samedi matin arrivera il fera vite deux
passagers
il ne vient que pour prendre en charge
les passagers qui descendront du bateau
de croisière pour retourner
en europe et si ce bateau fait l'objet
d'une alerte pour des cas sensibles
nous mettrons en place dans ce cas là un
corridor sanitaires pour que les
personnes qui quitteront le bateau pour
monter dans l'avion vers l'europe soit
encadré et sans mélange des flux liés au
port ni alerte une heure des changes
entre préfets et parlementaires avec
comme objectif informer en toute
transparence